who here has been to lightning talks
before or given one before should really
put your hand down if you don't wanna
give on now cuz I'm still looking for
volunteers sheets up there so lightning
talks are five minute quick talks you'll
get one idea out mister James in which
case you'll get about five but you get
five minutes and this is the whole fun
of it you get five minutes you will get
cut off after five minutes I'll be
keeping an eye on the time but you get
to talk about any topic you like it can
be PI data related it can be something
completely different in the past
lightning talks that I have gotten to
enjoy at various conferences have ranged
from in fact the ones that I haven't
enjoyed which come to mind most is
please come to my conference it's on in
you know six weeks please don't do that
we're not going to take those talks but
the more enjoyable ones have been things
like how I lost my pants at the attendee
party which was a starring her all at
Euro Python everyone enjoyed that one
and also someone completely analyzed
Star Wars in I don't remember the
details but that was interesting and a
little bit you know heartbreaking as a
fan because the results were not what I
wanted but you can come up and talk
about anything you want when it gets to
five minutes you'll get I'll get I'll
give you minute warnings so just so the
speakers know you'll get like a five
four three two one at each minute from
me for everyone else I'm gonna start
clapping when they get to zero time left
and you're just all going to join in and
if the speaker keeps going you're just
going to clap louder and if they keep
going you're gonna clap even ladder and
start cheering and eventually they'll
get the point and they'll wrap up and
leave but that's gonna happen at exactly
five minutes so even if it looks like
they're saying something interesting
we're still gonna cut them off and
they're gonna leave the stage and we'll
get on with the next one the plan is to
be done by six probably earlier if no
one willingly volunteers to give talks
we've already bribed and blackmailed as
many people as we can
hygena
and so our first is gonna be Gina
halfrek take it away hello everyone
my name is Gina halfrek I am
communications director for Numb focus
which is the nonprofit that puts on pie
data as an educational program and I
also am the program director for our
disc program which is diversity and
inclusion in scientific computing so my
talk today is on how diverse is pie data
and some challenges of answering that
question for an international conference
series there are a lot of things I'm not
gonna talk about which are of potential
interests with regard to this but just
putting that out there there you go and
you would think that answering the
question how diverse is pie data is
potentially simple what are the relevant
metrics survey the community about them
analyze the results so let's start at
the top select relevant diversity
metrics we've got tens of thousands of
people who have a data community not
only in our conferences but also in our
meetups there are many countries around
the world approximately 3,500 attendees
so actually going to ask ourselves if
we're thinking about the diversity of a
global community what does that really
mean are we thinking about in terms of
underrepresented
well what's underrepresented in the UK
is gonna look completely different from
what's underrepresented in Japan for
example so say we set that all aside and
just go gee now you know like what
diversity metrics are come on don't like
quit pulling my legs so maybe we would
track something like gender sexual
identity race etc like we can get into
further things right some other stuff
maybe I haven't put up here um and if we
do all that I think then we have to ask
ourselves the question of how do we get
this information both accurately and
responsibly so if we are gonna collect
this info how do you make ethical
choices about doing that and
categorizing your reporting the answers
so for example if we collect all this
stuff we're gonna have a hard time
preserving anonymity which might be very
important for some of the people who are
asking a
right um so there are quite a few things
that we need to take into account for
example if we ask about gender text box
is friendlier for people but providing
options is easier on the how are we
gonna actually sort this outside will we
alienate people by the way that we frame
the question are we gonna potentially
have women who are answering the
question be primed to answer other
questions later in a different way are
men gonna opt out because they feel like
this isn't for them if you guys about
race right how are we going to Singlish
raised from ethnicity same question
about text box versus providing options
it is an international comfort series so
if we change it based on location how do
we think about that right okay so we
have a lot of questions that we have to
decide upon answers to and you know make
our choices there so let's just set all
that aside and get to a survey the
community you think this is the
interesting and easy part a great survey
will get a 40 percent response rate
there's between 100 and thousand people
at every conference and for this crowd
I'm sure you're thinking how are we
gonna even assess something like what
that would mean right ten percent of a
100 person conference how diverse is pie
data and that really brings us to the
question of how we have intention
questions about accuracy of this
information versus collecting it
responsibly because we could say hey
we'll fix this problem by making
everything mandatory but if we make it
mandatory
that's not very responsible right so
responsible would be optional accurate
we've mandatories have to negotiate
these tensions and then you analyze
results and John that's it so I welcome
Thank You Jana
as an often underrepresented minority
myself I often wish that we had more
Windows Phone users of these conferences
Mike you up next and just to be prepared
looks like Joe is up next
or as ready I have not prepared jokes
this time to fill in the gap you are
welcome
I didn't prepare it that just happened
already okay Mike went from Nvidia and
I've talked today about GPU acceleration
how we're doing that with go away I in
Python but before I explain what guy is
I think we all can agree about this that
the data struggle is real whether it's
the data formats there's many of them
that are easier to work with some of
them more complicated once you figure
out your format and what you're trying
to do then you start becoming there's
the processing part so you know if we
think about the evolution of where we
were at
Hadoop batch dis space very long times
and all of a sudden there was just like
revolution right we went to spark 25 to
100 X speed up with less code the
language was more flexible you do Python
Scala Java and it was primarily in
memory so we got this tremendous boost
in speed however somebody was like you
know GPUs for the wind we're gonna be
able to bring them in they're gonna
change everything and everything would
be faster and the first time around it
didn't really work out too well we got
like a 5 to 10x speed improvement I mean
but the biggest problem here that was
like a barrier for most people was
there's more code the language is more
rigid you have to learn this thing
called CUDA and program and see and then
try to get that C kernel with CUDA like
to talk to your Python code and it just
it kind of like hampers things so my
colleague Keith and I we joined and we
were like you know we can do better
about this we can actually help the
community like do some awesome things
because there's these
gpu-accelerated technologies out there
like map d blazing DB which for DP you
databases anaconda and h2o AI for
processing and analytics and then
gunrock for graph analytics and graphs
tree for graphical civilizations all
based on the GPU and what we found was
these dreaded copy and converts so
that's all these red arrows we don't
like these because this is what's really
gonna hamper anything DP use fast when
it's on the GPU if I have to go off the
GPU everything just slows to a crawl cuz
I have to go through PCIe bus hit the
processor come back so even in this
small example how I want to move data
from map D to graphics tree to visualize
I got a bounce through the CPU so
ideally we want to get rid of that right
it's like no more if it's on the GPU I
should be able to share it and that's
where go AI or the GPU open analytics
initiative came in and we launched this
in May so it's a shared GPU data frame
that now I can actually handoff between
all of these GPU technologies and stay
on the GPU so once the data is there
it's there I basically handoff a pointer
now this now transforms how you're doing
a data processing pipeline because now
it's all on the GPU from ingestion to
parsing exploratory analytics the whole
pipeline and it was pioneered by map d
anaconda and h2o as the founding members
and then blazing BB gun rock and graph
trios also picked it up now how easy is
it use simple Python import statement
I'm going to import the PI G d/f and
everyone here loves pandas that's what
we usually use but in one line I can
actually go from a panda's data frame to
a GPU data frame and then by using some
decorators and numba I can actually tell
it take this the code snippet and I want
you to compile this down into CUDA I
don't have to learn CUDA I don't have to
do all the kernels and that kind of
stuff numbah actually takes care of all
this for us and big shout-out to
anaconda for doing a lot of the work on
this but it just doesn't stop there so
there's a lot of growing community
support for those of you that might know
Apache arrow West McKinney we've been
working with him they're actually
starting to add GPU support
into arrow why is that important because
the CPU technologies are having the same
problems when you're trying to go from
like spark to kudu Cassandra what have
you you're doing the copy converts and
we want to get rid of that so the GPU
data frame is actually actually compared
Oh compatible so if you're pulling data
out of these other places where the
arrow memory is you'd actually pull it
into a GPU data frame then be able to do
all this processing for model training
inference data manipulation all on the
GPU and then save the information back
and forth without having to do all this
copying convert serialization so where
does that bring us in our processing
evolution finally we're at that point
that we really wanted to get to do that
25 to 100 X speed improvement we're
using the same code we're just adding
the little decorators here and there to
do that and we're doing language
flexibility because you know keeping it
in Python so here's how you guys can get
involved winks to the go AI website
there's actually docker demos with
Jupiter notebooks and that kind of stuff
if you guys want to see how it all works
I encourage you to check it out Keis
back there and I'm here if you guys have
any questions thank you
well Joe is getting plugged in who made
it to the PI data quiz earlier today new
few people good for everyone else I'm
gonna throw a couple of questions from
that quiz at Uwe since you weren't there
and you don't know the answers who can
name a feature that is new in Python 3
call something out f strings Oh
everyone's favorite anything else matrix
multiply that's do you know exactly
which version that came in in 3.5 async
you and Python through it so async
generators it's not really a feature
there's a scary anything else what about
a new feature that was added 2 to 7 to 7
SEC comprehensions was added in 2/7
compared to six the the uninstall
feature was not new but it is
recommended Joe take it away alright
thank you so today I'm gonna talk about
a little toy library I wrote to
implement a feature called stream fusion
so what is true in fusion this is to
solve two problems the first problem is
when we have a code that looks like this
where we have map of f of filter of p of
map of g basically we have some sequence
of interleaved calls to map and filter
the other problem that I want to solve
is when we have code that looks like
this where we have map of f of map of G
so when you have long sequences where
you're mapping different functions over
the same sequence so as a quick
refresher map is a function which given
a function that acts on a scalar value
or single element and a sequence of
elements it applies that scalar function
to all elements in your sequence however
it does not mutate your sequence so the
original sequence is preserved filter is
a similar function we're given a scalar
predicate and a sequence of values it
valuates the predicate on all of the
values and takes only those for which
the predicate evaluates to true again it
does not mutate the original sequence so
given some code that looks like map of F
filter P map of G what is the actual
problem with this code so in Python this
code is actually going to have a lot of
extra function call overhead so the
first call is going to be on when we
call next on this large sequence the
first call is going to be too next on
the inner sequence which is the filter
which one we call next on that calls
next on the map which calls next on the
underlying sequence that we're mapping
over so we have three extra next calls
for every single call 10x in this
sequence so it doesn't seem like a lot
but this is gonna happen on every single
element in our sequence which can be
potentially quite large one thing to
note is that if you were to write this
code by hand instead of using map and
filter you would only have one call to
next
so you'd say for element in some input
iterator you would evaluate the map in
line by saying G of element you would
have your filter in line by saying if
not P of element continued and then you
would just yield your thing so to fix
this I wrote a class called go tanks
that fused that iterator which if you
have a scalar function like before we
can replace our call to map with a call
to fuse map and what this gives us is
instead of a map object it's a fused
iterator this keeps track of all of the
steps that we're going to apply to this
sequence instead of actually building up
some object that loses that information
but if we iterate over it we get the
same value that we'd expect from that
this becomes useful when you want to
start sequencing things for example if
we have some interleaving like from
before we can still see what all those
steps are and then when we evaluate it
we get the same result the reason this
is faster is that instead of using a
bunch of Python function call overhead I
take all those steps and I wrote a
little interpreter loop in C++ which
just goes through that really really
quickly in a single stack frame and
executes it the other problem I talked
about was map of map so given two scalar
functions and a sequence if we apply map
to both of them we get this result but
this is actually equivalent to saying
map of F composed with G so we can fold
those two map calls into a single map
call with a function called F of G which
just calls F of G of X when we call map
of this we get the same value however if
we were to write this F of G by hand we
would not actually call F and G we would
just inline the body so to take a look
at the bytecode for these functions if
we have F this says load fast load cons
binary ad return value you can look up
what those means later G is almost the
same except we're going to use a binary
multiply instead of a binary ad so the F
of G does basically the two things
together except there's no temporaries
so our goal is to take our
map of F of map of G and generate this F
of G that has the same properties as our
handwritten code so to do that I wrote a
function called compose which takes two
functions and returns a new function and
this function actually has the same byte
code as the handwritten version
ourselves so if you use go text at fused
map and you say map of f of map of G now
we only have one step and that's a
single map step of F of G and it gives
us the same result thank you joy next up
is James pal well James is getting set
up we all use Python we all use a lot of
the libraries and there's some very
valuable and very important people
behind those projects to contribute a
lot of volunteer time to make them work
I don't know if this question came up in
the quiz today but has in the past who
can name a core contributor to any of
the major projects that we use C Python
numpy pandas Syfy Jeffrey RAC or project
anders anyone else brett cannon C Python
Steve Dawa who's that nobody important
speaking of nobody important that's like
James's time is starting a minute ago
fantastic so I want to show you some
ideas I've had recently about a topic
that I don't care enough about to write
real slides for but a topic I do really
care about cuz I spent a lot of time
thinking about this and I think the
genesis of thinking about this idea came
from a pet project that I had and then
just something very simple that I do in
a jupiter notebook you know what a
jupiter notebook you have these magic
commands you put a percent sign in front
of something and it does something
different in the case of Piran this
isn't valid Python it tells a notebook
to do something special like profile the
code that you have and you even have
these cell level ones so you can cite
the NIH's a cell you do a kind of neat
stuff like
run shell commands from your Jupiter
notebook and what's kind of cool is that
those shell commands can also interact
with the Python environment so I can set
a variable in Python and then I can
write a shell command and the
environment of that shell includes the
state of that it's kind of neat well I
decided that I hate PowerPoint and I
hate writing slides so why not create my
own tool for writing slides and I
originally started with a tool called
sent from a group called suck list it
was a very very simple tool what you had
was a single text file and in that text
file you would have each slide separated
with lines and so a slideshow might look
something like this some slide is the
first slide with content second slide
third part is that's it the problem is
that's too stripped down so I thought
wouldn't it be nice if I wrote my own
version in Python the original version
in C was a thousand lines I can write a
version of this in Python in about 200
lines of code I was able to do it and I
thought wouldn't it be nice if I could
set the foreground color so you know I
can make this a red slide just to give
impact because having every slide the
same color doesn't give the right kind
of impact and wouldn't it be nice if I
could change the font on certain slides
wouldn't it be nice if I could add small
things here and there and as you as this
became more and more complicated I
started adding more and more directives
and I thought wouldn't it be nice if my
slides could run some Python code so I
could display the time and eventually it
turned into this monstrosity this is the
very first version of my slideshow
program and what the data format looked
like and you can see there's a million
directives some of these directives
include Python code that runs there's
this burn after reading directive
because these directives would create a
phony slide that I have to delete so the
number the counting wouldn't go right
and I was writing Python code and
cutting and pasting it and it was
horrible this worked for a couple of
presentations by the way you won't be
able to tell which ones are in which
tool because from the perspective of the
output it all looks the same but it
ended up looking like this you can see
there's timers there's global variables
and I said I need to take a step back
and I need to think how to do this right
and what I thought about was I like to
write Python I like to write Python
scripts and back when I was a kid you
know we learned yak in school we learned
yak and by son in school one kind of
neat thing that a lot of us forget about
those tools is that yes it's a parser
generator and
yes parsers are supposedly well-trodden
in computer science but I don't really
want to write a parser it's still kind
of hard to do but one neat thing about
yak is it would embed see in the
language so this is actually a line of
see no just get embed it yak would just
translate one file into C so I thought
what are the sigils that are not
available at the beginning of a line in
Python what are the ones that are
available to me to the line and what
what if I just took a Python script and
I added a couple of lines that I could
identify specifically as not being valid
Python because they start with a
character like per like exclamation
point or % that aren't valid Python and
I just used a regular expression
transform to transform it directly into
Python and I realized that this is
actually a very powerful technique
either using a regular expression
transform or just using eval on it
directly and so I ended up with
something that looked like this now this
looks very complicated but in in fact
what I'm doing here is I'm constructing
a Python object just using regular
function calls and I just have a little
bit of extra language that just says
create a function here pass it through
these two functions and take this and
what I can do now is I can create very
complex object hierarchies with a very
simple dialect for a fairly
sophisticated data format and I don't
have to write a parser I don't have to
do anything except just notate what is
actually originally maybe a Python file
with a couple of sigils and either do a
regular expression transform or just
search for lines that start with my
magic character and pass them to the
Python eval as a result I end up
embedding not I ended up embedding a
Python interpreter into the DSL
whichever way you want to say that
you're embedding but you end up turning
what was originally data file into
something that's actually a transpiled
Python script getting all the power of
Python not having to write a parser
outside of a couple of really simple
regular expression transforms and you do
some really amazing things with this now
obviously probably I'll go back to this
in the end because this is probably the
easiest thing to do but I think it's a
very interesting idea I think there's a
lot of legs to this idea and I've been
thinking now as I start writing software
I don't want to write configuration
formats that have includes I don't want
to I don't want my Dada formats to start
getting programmed behavior I want them
to be a simple fix
thank you James got to say I've seen a
number of lightning talks up here if
you're here you're up next number of
lightning talks but that's the first one
where I've ever seen someone reinvent
latech and then and then Java and then
Ruby all in one lightning talk so since
we're getting set up let's let's hear a
few more core maintain errs because we
do want to recognize these people they
contribute a lot does anyone know anyone
who works on numpy nathaniel smith see i
see actually a core maintainer are just
very very active he's officially now I
know he's very active I'm not gonna
repeat that on the microphone anyone
else anyone know anyone who works on
scikit-learn yeah yep good sorry Gail
yes what about Jacob yep what about Syfy
does anyone use Syfy nobody he uses Syfy
okay does anyone use a strop I know no
or the astronomers have gone home is it
a clear night sorry Thomas Robertson
matplotlib Tom Caswell I'm all the ones
coming to mind our for me at least of
the Anaconda ones and I don't I I know
who those people are
good yep all right cool
so the other week I was competing in a
competition for predicting water
failures with a couple friends and we
had this big feature space looking at
everything from soil data to topological
data to where exactly the pipes laid and
weather data and we just needed to
create this classifier where we needed
to hit a prediction within a six month
window so as we kind of divided the
tasks I was in charge of creating the
temporal features so I used the profit
library which many of you may have
already used and Ts fresh to do that
very very quickly so I want to show you
how I did that so first let's just
define a simple function for creating an
arbitrary time series with some trend
and noise and it'll look something like
this
then I went ahead and assigned a period
so in this case the contest required
that we make these six-month predictions
so we needed to know if this pipe would
fail within the six month period so
that's why I'm assigning a period here
but that would be you know some
identifier that you would want to group
on you know with with some other type of
forecasting experiment so in this case
it looks something like this where you
know I just take the year in the month
and then we have our time series that
looks like this so the profit library
makes it really easy to go ahead and
apply forecast so if we passed in that
full time series we would get out
something like this you can see the
forecast vector beginning right about
there so the next thing I did was create
a feature prep function this is really
ugly because I wrote it just earlier
today but basically it goes through and
it says okay for a given six month
period well for a given time series
we'll go ahead and make a 12 month
forecast and then the first six months
of that forecast we're going to take
some descriptive statistics over it to
squeeze out some features we'll then
take the percentage difference with the
prior six months over the forecast
vector and then we'll squeeze out the
same descriptive statistics from that so
when all is said and done you know goes
through all the different six month
periods creates all the different
forecasts and then we get back
or a data frame that looks something
like this or we'll have like the trends
some the trend mean the trend median any
of the descriptive stats that I passed
in here I just did some mean median min
and Max and then if you scroll all the
way over here we can see some of the
percentage change descriptive stats that
we squeezed out as well so that's all
well and good we went from that one kind
of discrete interval 291 features but
we're not done so we went ahead and
passed in the another data frame to TS
fresh and we are grouping on that that
column ID and it knows that that d s is
our time series and that will squeeze
out another 795 features so TS fresh is
pretty exhaustive and some of the
features that will create not all of
them help explain variants so you may
want to limit that space somewhat but
very quickly we went from you know just
that that one feature you know the the
discrete interval to 795 plus the 91 so
then we just go ahead and merge those
two data frames and we get 885 time
serious features so you know pretty
pretty nice I did relatively small data
here just those 13 steps obviously not
enough to train a classifier but if you
are in a situation where you think some
additional temporal features might help
improve the performance of a classifier
you know this is a quick and easy way to
get there and just using some really
simple tricks and some really high-level
libraries that's it thank you thank you
up next is David Nicholson ready sir
okay well he's getting ready I just want
to call out a couple of sponsors again
since we're down to the last two maybe
three lightning talks it's really
exciting I'm seeing a lot of sponsored
of companies sponsoring that I've not
seen sponsored by data before and that's
really cool you can all see the signs up
here Bloomberg dejour Capital One the
eight
elasticity kubal 0 AI stick commute
stick a mule sponsored before they've
been buying stickers off them forever
but it's really exciting to see new
companies getting involved helping
support the community and we're really
happy that if if anyone representing
them is still here really happy that you
decided to help sponsor pi data and we
hope that will continue because it's
great to have more involvement david
thanks hey how about ralph commerce for
a sigh hi maintainer he helped me
through my first commit so i want to
give him a shout out hey I'm David
Nicholson here from Emory where I'm a
postdoc in the silver lab I gave to talk
about neural networks for segmenting
vocalization with yard and Cohen this
morning but now I'm here for my night
job which is teaching data science to
scientists how many people in this room
and you don't have to answer because
that would be irresponsible as I learned
from Gina how many people will have like
an academic background which can include
starting grad school and then saying
screw this ok so for the 10 of you how
many of you still interact with people
in academia yeah ok cool right so so you
probably know all fields of science are
now flooded in actual digital data that
you can manipulate with your computer
scientists really need data science
training especially grad students not
only to better deal with their data but
to have actual hard skills from your
degree that you can use in academia and
out so not all fields of study or
programs have recognized this need right
you might think of astrophysics as being
really good about this like Jake van der
pause Cady Huffman physics right there
like the keynotes at PyCon neuroscience
we like to think that we're studying the
most complex thing in the universe but
we still have a little work to do in
this respect and especially in programs
there's often this prerequisite pipeline
so I think all of us in this room even
though we might not have had like 12
years of calculus are not afraid to just
use scikit-learn but if you want to take
a machine learning class often you have
to have that in your
you're in your history of classes you've
already taken so and here's a one list
that a grad student put together in our
program to emphasize this how hard it is
to get in these classes because they're
very siloed so we've been trying to
address this need at Atlanta we have
this best program which is broadening
experiences in scientific education and
our program manager Tammy Hutto along
with Sarah to Kushi who's the student
that put that list together they just
sort of started organically this data
science club and it might not surprise
you to find out that we've had a ton of
people interested in that along with the
club we started a github organization
which has really been a great tool to
organize and also been a way for them to
get some exposure to those tools and
also I'm teaching a short course on
scientific computing and data science or
as I wrote here on data scientist so our
club
we've got monthly meetings we're
organizing on slack which has its pros
and cons but again that's a way for them
to see that we took we give
presentations on topics of interest like
getting github and we've had panel
discussions so we've been able to work
with PI data Atlanta and Anna data which
is an another local group which is a
local group that um has its own github
projects that that our members can work
on and for our github org
you know we put all our repos based on
the talks up on our org page we have a
list of contacts where we had everyone
in the club submit so that was another
way for them to see what it's like to
use git and also when we have to show
professors and administrators hey we
really need to address this need if you
have a list of 60 people who without any
you know reason for them to sign up and
learn how to use git except you know
their own interest and they're all on
this page it provides some really good
evidence that this need does need to be
addressed and then last but not least we
have our data science short course that
we've been teaching we've been using
software carpentry classes as a basis
some of the free books from Jake van der
Paz like the data science handbook which
is really good for how do I do this
command I learned in MATLAB in Python
and then elegans type I just want to
give a shout out to that it's a really
awesome book because it's very example
based so it starts out with you know
talking about how do I go from gene to a
protein and then how do i do
bioinformatics and then how do I use
numpy and it's super user friendly if
you're someone who's like still afraid
of a computer but and you're doing your
analysis and Excel but you work in the
lab every day right so and last but not
least our class project is sort of
trying to tie all those those things
together and on my last slide I'm not
going to segue to it by saying last but
not least but um just to emphasize the
take homes we need data science
education as scientists there are these
open source tools out here but please
check out my links on the slides when I
tweet them out and learn from our trial
and error and thanks for listening thank
you David I'm gonna take advantage of
being the presenter here and insert my
own lightning talk because I can
[Music]
which means I get to do my entire means
I get to cut myself off so this could go
on for a while it won't okay my name's
Steve Dawa I work at Microsoft I'm also
a sip and core contributor as we shout
it out before I'm actually speaking
tomorrow I've got a full session on this
but I decided to pull out one slide now
and in fact two slides and go a little
deeper for all you lovely people who
stuck around today
I've already chatted with a few people
through my slides and they're not real
excited about me not spending much time
on this so my talk tomorrow is why does
why do we need security transparency in
Python the full answer for that will be
tomorrow but this is a sneak peek
because I suspect not many people have
actually seen how to exploit a security
vulnerability in Python and that is what
this is an example of right here we're
probably all vaguely familiar with the
idea of buffer buffer overruns being a
bad idea remote code execution being a
really bad thing to let happen but how
does it actually come about what do you
have to do to make that happen so what I
have here is a sample it's taken from
the website below I didn't come up with
this this is an example packet that you
would send to a Python server that's
written in Python I suspect it'll say
the link I think this one was fixed in
about two seven nine is when this bug
was fixed but essentially what this
would do is a server using the socket
don't receive from function he's going
to receive this message and it's going
to copy it into a local buffer that
buffers allocated on the stack so if you
remember back to you early saw for
engineering maybe you learnt C you dealt
with a stack certainly Python has a
stack but this gets written into the C
stack this is just flat memory that is
all just ones and zeros and the program
logic determines how it gets interpreted
so there's a section that this gets
written into answer and gets called data
somewhere else in memory adjacent to
that is another section that says this
is the next bit of code to run this is
the return address to jump to when we're
finished with this function there's
other bits of this memory that say here
is the start of my parameter here's the
where the important information is
located so it's this mix of
local variables addresses code pointers
and it's all just thrown into one chunk
of memory which means if you find a way
that you can overrun a data part of that
you can start changing the actual which
bit of code is going to be executed next
so if you look at this packet you'll see
a whole lot of things that look like
padding and they are if I take out all
of the generated padding that's just to
fill spaces and get to the right place
the highlighted hexadecimal numbers are
actually hex those should all have like
backslash X escapes but that looked ugly
so I left them out but what this will do
if you are in the received Fromme
function that's the implementation in
Python certain versions this would
overflow a buffer it just gets copied
into a local array no bounds checking no
range lay all of that stuff just gets
ignored and you end up overwriting some
variables you'll say the first two
values are the same that's to actually
make it keep working because one of
those values is important and if you
change it then everything just breaks
and you don't get an exploit you get a
crash so we have to write in the value
to make it work the last value the one
that starts with a zero that's actually
the address of the system function in
the particular version of G Lib C that
this is trying to exploit while security
vulnerabilities are scary
while buffer overflows are definitely
vulnerabilities you have to be very very
precise to take advantage of them
because if you sent this to a machine
that doesn't have the system function
there you're not going to get a
vulnerability you're not going to get an
exploit you're going to get a seg fault
which is you know valuable in some times
but not necessarily what you want it
also happens to continue overriding and
it overrides the argument to that
function which means this code run on a
machine that is targeted to is going to
start an instance of bash we're using
the system command it's a proof of
concept that's not a full vulnerability
you'd more likely have something fun
like this something that's actually
going to use a good programming tool
that can run arbitrary code
that in a single line pasta system can
download it from anywhere on the
internet compile it
no validation no nothing it's just going
to grab your arbitrary code and run it
on someone else's machine because they
didn't patch their version of Python
this is the scary part of the story if
you want to hear the happy ending you
have to come to my talk tomorrow it's
going to be in the afternoon look it up
why does Python need security
transparency my name's Steve Dawa I will
see you there thank you and I didn't go
over at all our final talk is she ready
yay
okay well jessica is getting plugged in
let's have a look at these other
sponsors that are over the other side
Microsoft hosting isn't it great to have
such awesome facilities to hang out in
yeah you can clap obviously I work there
I wasn't directly involved in setting
this conference up but we're thrilled to
have you and happy to welcome you and
hope to do it again in the future
anaconda has been sponsoring PI data
since the start which is great
Ameritrade JPMorgan to Sigma Caserta and
crux and I love seeing these companies
that have not sponsored before I hope
you guys stick around it's wonderful to
have you as part of the community and
with that our final lightning talk for
the night whenever you're ready that
flux flux is saying we should all be in
bed now if you don't know what flux is
by the way this is it it adjusts the
temperature of your screen so that in
time with the Sun setting so it actually
makes it so that you don't get eye
strain late at night because you go
ridiculously bright screen but it also
means that during the day when your eyes
can handle it because outdoors is bright
your screen can be bright as well
disable next one down don't use it if
you're an artist because it's going to
confuse you okay so my name is Jessica
Ford I work with the great people at
project Jupiter and you can too so this
point of this talk is that all of you
can be working on project Jupiter and I
would hope you all end up working on
this so the the last time I was at a
Python conference that there wasn't this
one I gave a talk on reinforcement
learning and it now that we have Jupiter
lab there is a great new way to explore
repose we have an IDE and so instead of
me just going through the environment
the notebook like this I can actually
highlight all this and send it to the
console and now this whole thing is
running and everything talks to each
other and it's all modular and we have a
lot of really nice additional tools so
for example if I can do this all at the
same time I can actually put up this
puppy I know I can render it so it
renders markdown and all of this is
really great right and I can keep on
going about all these great things but
you know what like you guys probably
actually want to be able to get it on
your own so I set up a delightful little
environment yeah mall if I click on it
twice it'll open so
has everything you need and that sounds
cool but that's actually not cool enough
because ultimately what I really want is
all of you guys to be able to play with
it on your own so I'm going to show you
guys another tool so I'm gonna pull up
this thing I'm sorry I'm trying to do I
get the mouse where's the where's my
mouse let's see um disconnect okay
where's my mouse there's the mouse right
in the top right okay I keep going right
does it end up going left
sorry I can't figure out how to drive
this thing
does anybody have like or is it how do I
get it on the other side do I go left to
get to them my side there it is okay
I go to binder now you guys all can hit
play with it as well so if I go so this
is actually a my binder instance of the
same notebook and it has everything
pre-installed and you guys can all play
with it which is great and we also take
our studio we take Jupiter lab we
checked you for a notebook and so you
actually can use it on your own right
now it's just it's totally live and
there it is but I think you know since
open-source is really important I'm
going to cut to some other things that
we can do with Jupiter lab that I
thought you guys might find really fun
so I'm going to show you one my favorite
things about Jupiter lab which is
real-time collaboration and so I'm gonna
go open up sea driving this thing and so
this is a notebook that we I have that
I've been working with for a while we we
play with it all the time and I can run
things live alright it just runs and
let's see
[Music]
and I'm actually sharing this with Dan
so let's see where where are you down
see where is Dan ah there is there's Dan
see so that's down so we can so now when
you connect a jupiter lab to Google
Drive you can do real-time collaboration
again these are all different projects
that are open-source all of you can work
on it we have Sprint's on Friday it's
totally great one of the things actually
that I would really hope you guys all
think about is possibly even building
your own extensions so we have so
Jupiter lab is entirely modular we use
all the latest tools in web app
development so there's we use typescript
we use yarn all these sorts of things
and there's a really great there's a
really great tutorial online on how you
can build extensions we have an xkcd
extension which are really great so
please contribute thank you let's thank
all of our speakers
that is lightning talks for tonight hey
keynote starts tomorrow at 9:00 a.m.
it's going to be back in here we have a
Nobel Prize winner in here you want to
come in here Tom Sargent speak very
interesting man looking forward to what
we'll see you tomorrow morning 9:00 a.m.
for the second day of payday to New York
I guess
[Applause]